nos dicen la gráfica de que igual a la
raíz de x se muestra a continuación
entendido esta es la gráfica en morado y
nos preguntan cuál de las siguientes es
la gráfica t y es igual a dos veces la
raíz cuadrada de menos x menos 1
y nos dan varias opciones así que te
encargó pausa el vídeo intenta encontrar
la gráfica correspondiente antes de que
lo trabajemos juntos
ok vamos a trabajar juntos y vamos a
intentar dibujar la gráfica de i es
igual a dos veces la raíz cuadrada de
menos x y después menos 1
la vamos a relacionar con la opción que
más se parezca la forma de dibujarla
será paso a paso ya sabemos que la
gráfica de morado es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de x
ahora vamos a modificar esta expresión y
queremos encontrar la gráfica de que es
igual a la raíz cuadrada y en lugar de
poner a x adentro del radical ahora
pondremos a menos x cómo afectará la
gráfica bueno lo que pasa en un cierto
valor de x ahora pasará en el negativo
de ese valor de x la raíz cuadrada no
está definida para el números negativos
pero si es igual a la raíz cuadrada de
menos x no estará definida para números
positivos
el comportamiento en x igual a 4 ahora
lo tendrás en x igual a menos 4 y así
sigue por lo tanto la gráfica de ye
igual a la raíz cuadrada de menos x
se parece a algo así
esencialmente tuvimos una reflexión
sobre el eje ya bien ya tenemos esta
parte ahora vamos a escalar al
multiplicar por 2 cuál es la gráfica de
ye igual a dos veces la raíz cuadrada de
menos x bueno se parece a esta gráfica
de rojo pero ahora cada valor x dado
tendrá el doble de altura n que es igual
a 4 en lugar de obtener el valor de 2
ahora obtenemos el valor de 4 n que es
igual a 9 en lugar de obtener el valor
de 3
ahora obtenemos el valor de 6 en x está
igual a 0 seguiremos en el valor de cero
porque 2 x 0 es cero así la gráfica se
parece a algo así
esta es la gráfica de dos veces la raíz
cuadrada de menos x por último pero no
menos importante cuál es la gráfica de y
es igual a dos veces la raíz cuadrada de
menos x menos uno bueno el valor que
teníamos antes
ahora vamos a desplazarlo una unidad
hacia abajo si estábamos en 6 ahora
estaremos en 5 si estábamos en 4 ahora
estaremos en 3 si estábamos en 0 ahora
estaremos en menos 1 por lo tanto la
curva que buscamos se ve algo así así
que veamos qué opción se parece a esto
si bajamos la pantalla c&d parecen
correctas pero recuerda en 0 obtenemos
el valor de menos 1 así que te es
exactamente lo que dibujamos en menos 9
obtenemos un valor de 5 en menos 4
obtenemos un valor de 3 en 0 el valor de
menos 1 es exactamente como la dibujamos
bien hagamos otro ejemplo
tenemos una pregunta similar ahora
gráfica en la curva igual a la raíz
cúbica de x y nos preguntan cuál de las
siguientes es la gráfica de que es igual
a menos la raíz cúbica de x + 2 y
después más 5 y de nuevo nos dan opción
múltiple una vez más pausa el vídeo e
intenta trabajar por tu cuenta antes de
que lo trabajemos juntos
bien vamos a trabajar juntos y voy a
utilizar la misma técnica vamos a
transformar la expresión paso a paso
inicialmente tenemos la gráfica de esto
igual a la raíz cúbica de x y primero
queremos tener adentro del radical en
lugar de x a x + 2 así que pensemos en
la gráfica de que es igual a la raíz
cúbica de x + 2 bueno lo que hace este +
2 es desplazar la gráfica 2 a la
izquierda ya hemos visto esto en varios
vídeos anteriores así que ahora estamos
aquí podemos probar con algún valor para
verificar en x igual a menos 2 obtenemos
la raíz cúbica de 0 que es 0 y estamos
aquí así que nos hemos desplazado 2 a la
izquierda y se parece a algo así
ahora vamos a multiplicar por este signo
negativo y es igual a menos
la raíz cúbica de x + 2
como se ve esta gráfica
si multiplicas toda la expresión o en
este caso toda la función por un signo
negativo tenemos una reflexión sobre el
eje horizontal por lo tanto ahora se ve
así
sea cual sea anteriormente el valor de
que ahora para una x dada obtienes el
negativo de ese valor
jeff por último pero no menos importante
cuál es la gráfica en un color apropiado
de igual a menos la raíz cúbica de x + 2
ya esto más 5 lo único que vamos a hacer
es desplazar la gráfica hacia arriba 5
unidades sea cual sea anteriormente el
valor de james ahora para una x dada
obtienes un valor 5 unidades arriba así
que si estábamos en 0 5 unidades arriba
ahora estamos en 5 y por lo tanto la
gráfica se ve algo así no la estoy
dibujando de manera perfecta pero la
idea general es buscar una opción que se
parezca a ésta
la clave es buscar este punto en nuestra
gráfica original estaba en 0 0 ahora
estamos en menos 25 además hemos girado
ahora tenemos la parte ascendente a la
izquierda y la parte descendente a la
derecha bien vamos a buscarla
y se tiene en la parte ascendente a la
izquierda y la parte descendente a la
derecha pero queremos este punto en
menos 25
y no tiene el punto que buscamos ve
tampoco lo tiene y ya hemos dicho que te
va en la dirección contraria así que
tampoco es la opción correcta bien
veamos
- 25 está en el punto esperado y es muy
cercana a la gráfica que dibujamos así
que esta es nuestra opción correcta